We need one dog team for a road sweep and surrounding area check
Leavey, dog up
I just don't know why you want to do this.
Yeah, I know you don't
You don't really connect with people very well
Just to you know running away is not gonna solve anything.
Hang up that phone! Talk to you shortie
Found something
Good boy.
And we watching this dog are all here.
He's the most aggressive dog I've ever treated
Does It really need another break.
Like he's earned it
You're getting a dog.
You got this? Think faster. Yeah, I got this
You think I'm afraid of you? Lay down, Rex lay down
Vehicle approaching
Guns up
Why'd you join?
To get away from my life?
Shipping out tomorrow
We are so not ready for this
Clear!
Leavey, check that vehicle
Here come
Where's my dog? I need to see him
You cannot come back to my house like some big-war hero. Back off mom
You can't let your whole life fall apart over some dog.
That dog saved my life
Please just changes classification so that I can adopt him when he gets back.
They aren't pet, they're warriors
Senators can I just have a moment of your time
His name is Rex, he saves thousands of lives in Iraq?
What do you say your name was?
Corporal Megan Leavey
All you had to do is fight
You not afraid, you're a marine
What would you say to Rex if he were here? I'd thank him for teaching me what love is